i love museums i go to museums all the
time love art me too
i'm recently single so me too
awesome okay i love it i believe that
each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense on the show today
is
chef eron sanchez chef and i go back
quite a ways so he's such a nice guy
such a high vibe guy
totally blaze the trail from his mother
onto him
in the world of mexican creole cooking
he has a memoir called where i came from
if anyone is interested in
reading more in depth about his
childhood and
and him becoming a chef he comes from
three generations
of women who've wrote cookbooks his mom
has been a huge inspiration
for him we talked about you know
addiction
and and his father and um you know
relationships and
just all of the things that have taught
us lessons over the years and
what those lessons have done to create a
man who
knows how to balance life better
uh now than he ever used to so
please enjoy today's episode with chef
eron
how are you oh look at you you've got
the wine
you betcha you bet you're skippy i'm all
about it oh
you're this sweet oh my god that's so
awesome
where did you i mean where did you get
it from
i can't tell you from one of your
distributors here in new orleans
and they sent it to me to make sure that
i'm able to support you and we can talk
a little bit of wine and
i'm excited about that that's cool
that's cool that was actually
that was the last time we saw each other
was in yeah new orleans
yeah yeah that was a lot of fun we need
to get a proper hang next time okay
we'll go out to have dinner okay
oh i yes absolutely you're not cooking
and neither am i we're going to let
someone else do it for us
all about it absolutely would love that
you look great
i'm so happy are you having a decent
summer uh with all
things considering no it's absolutely
horrible it's 20 20. look at you
just killing it yeah absolutely
well you sent it to me so i mean it's
important for me to you know
kind of understand the jews oh man
you're associated do you love i mean do
you love wine i don't even know i do
yeah
you know it's funny when i was a kid
when i was a kid like my mom would
always like give us a little taste and
just say you know start to embrace
wine because you don't want to have a
fantastic meal with iced tea
you know what i'm saying and it's like
they work together
so she kind of always instilled that's
in me and my my twin brother
very early on and um i mean i know your
mom's a huge chef so
the fact that she introduced you to wine
as well kind of makes her a superhero
yeah absolutely you know and also
there's something to like
starting drinking wine really young and
it not being some overwhelming big cool
thing where
you know you just kind of like little
dabs here and there
tell me more about your mom yeah my mom
is just you know that's why i think i
relate so much and i admire you so much
it's because i'm just used to having
strong women in my life whether it was
my grandmother
my mom um and then my sister who also
worked with me in the restaurants for
many years so my mom basically was a
social worker
and um a caterer in el paso texas where
i was born
and then early on she grew up in a
mexican cattle ranch in northern mexico
and um you know was sort of cultivated
and
and started to flourish there and then
moved to el paso i met my dad
um and then my mom my dad didn't have a
good run necessarily but she always
wanted to have her name in lights
and she says i'm going to have my name
and lights so she went
uh to new york city to chase her dream
of being a chef in a restauranteur
did she get her name in lights she did
yeah
yeah how did that how well
she went initially to new orleans
where i'm at now i called my home and
she met paul perdom the
great uh sort of iconic american
regional chef from louisiana and
they struck up a friendship they became
dear friends
and then chef paul said what are you
doing salela my mom's name is
zarella she said well i'm divorced i got
twin boys
and i'm looking to start this career
journey
and he made a call to warner leroy
who owned tavern on the green in new
york city and then my mom came in the
early 80s
and started cooking mexican food and at
that time people didn't
they were just flabbergasted they never
tasted those flavors
and that's how her name started to go
out there and
and be known and she would invite food
critics and writers and all like the
movers and shakers of new york at the
time
and that's how she started to become
known and then when she opened up her
own restaurant in 1987
it just took off from there that blows
my mind to think that people were only
being introduced as sort of
would it be like mexican creole flavor i
mean what was her what was her
what was her like how did she cook what
was her flavor profile
it was just very traditional stuff that
my grandmother and they cooked at the
ranch it was straight mexican food but
you know you have to you know remember
at that time people's
interpretation or perception of mexican
food was gloppy
orange cheese and all that stuff you
know what i mean
so i didn't have the sort of nuances and
the delicate
techniques and flavors that really
mexican food is now
so my mom was a absolute trailblazer
just like you
in your field absolute trailblazer so
you know that's that's some that's
amazing to me
to think that only a few decades ago
people were only being introduced to
high quality fine refined
mexican cuisine yeah and and
what was harder for us was to procure
the ingredients i remember being a child
and having to like come back from trips
to mexico in the summer and bring back
bales of chilis
we were like chili meals it was awesome
we'd bring spices and all this stuff
because we couldn't find it
here in the states and now everything is
obtainable
and it's it's just it's goes to show you
how 30 years changes things
are there still a few things that you
get from mexico that you can't get here
a few little yeah there's like some of
the more obscure
the obscure chilies they make these
really beautiful
tamarind little candies that are dusted
with chili that are like super addictive
and you're just like these little
tart little candies um yeah there's tons
of stuff
but you know heirloom corn varieties
that you can't get
so i'm like when i go to i'm going to
mexico on thursday
um because i'm you know in the process
of launching a tequila line
so i'm gonna go out there and taste uh
some tequilas and
and kind of figure out what what i want
to do you know
so i'll bring back some snacks i mean i
love wine yes that's
like i mean like i was out on a boat all
weekend and i just
and i tried to drink wine it's a little
tough so my
like i do but i do so the other things
that i would drink would pretty much
only be tequila or vodka and club soda
so um i want to know more about this
tequila
yeah well tequila is one of the it's
it's a spirit that is
emblematic of mexican culture yeah uh
jalisco where guadalajara is which is
the capital of jalisco
is some people consider the most mexican
of states because
that's where mariachi music is from they
have
a lot of iconic food dishes like beeria
and enchiladas and
and and all these really kind of very
iconic dishes
and then if you go about an hour outside
of guadalajara you find
los altos and in tequila where they
produce
all the tequila and it's like think of
it as a napa
you know where you would go and just see
instead of you know vineyards you just
see cactus and agave on each side
you know what i mean and uh so it's
you know everyone uh is very you know
astute about
you know trying to make a tequila but
there's a lot of crappy tequila just
like there's a lot of crappy wine
sure but tequila in the last five years
has exploded 300
as far as sales and people wanting it so
um
you know i've always been a fan and i've
you know it's something that connects me
to my culture so
i thought this would be a good time to
do it so what um
what makes one tequila better or worse
than another
like i could name ways in the wine
business where you know
things could you know adjust the flavor
but i don't know anything about tequila
like that
yeah well you know a lot of it has to do
with
the quality of the agave there's many
different uh styles of cactus or agave
that you can distill the product from
just like grapes
um and then yes there's a certain degree
when you when you're talking about
aging you know the three styles that are
most prominent or
uh plata or silver blanco right
um preposado which means rested and then
which means aged so um
yeah so it takes about nine years
you know seven to nine years to actually
mature the agave to make the juice right
um but it just really depends on what
you want to have to go what the flavor
profile you want
like for me i like herbal notes i like
minerality
i like i don't you know i don't like it
too sweet but you know american palettes
tend to like sweetness
so this is the the process this is the
the the point of this trip this week
to figure out that flavor profile that
we want so
what um so where does that fall in for
you is that a silver
or is that yeah we're gonna yeah we're
gonna launch a silver
and a reposado we're not gonna mess with
anyakos just yet
because those are just better sellers i
think i like reposado the best that's my
favorite
it's sort of the most i don't know it
tastes the most
um it has flavor without
being abrasive yeah
exactly you know you can tell a crappy
tequila
when it's hot you know when you taste it
it's pure alcohol and it burns
that means it's a shitty tequila you
know but if it has those nuances on the
front palette
you know what i was talking about you
know the herbaceousness the little bit
of citrus notes
little minerality then you're dealing
with something different
so it's just like wine you know you have
to have a good producer
what about mezcal is that a whole is
that just like an added flavor is that a
whole different
agave plant or yeah well it's different
agaves but
the biggest difference is first of all
mezcal all tequila's mezcal
but not all mezcal is tequila you
understand it's so it's a precursor
to tequila they've been making they've
been making mezcal
indigenous people in mexico for two
thousand years
so it actually predates tequila by a lot
wow so in the biggest difference between
mezcal
and tequila is that the pina right so
you have the cactus they take the root
of that which is called the pina because
it looks like a pineapple
okay and then they roast that it's fire
roasted
and the littler take like a donkey that
will work go in circles with like a big
a stone crusher and it just crushes the
the the agave and makes it sap in this
in this beautiful juice and that's how
you make moscow
and the old school way now they now
they've modernized it but yeah
yeah they don't still do that but i mean
okay but there's a romantic side of it
cool
but that's the old way that they used to
do it they used to have
did you say a donkey yeah with a with
like connected to a steel
i mean like a stone wheel that would
crush
you know it's kind of like with wine
when people used to step on grapes right
you know back in the day
yeah yeah okay so mezcal is just the
the sm the roasting or smoking of the
of the yeah the root of the of the grape
and so if you were going to only make if
you weren't going to make mezcal you
just wouldn't roast it
yeah basically and then you would you
could either put in stainless steel like
you would do like a shablee right
a chardonnay you know if you want to do
that with no oak
and then you know reposala would would
touch oak you know
like a blanco you wouldn't put an oak oh
so tequila does go in
oh girls absolutely yeah absolutely
how long does it age for well it depends
you know i mean
sometimes it's it's it's you know you've
got one to three years for a repo
sometimes like three to five for an
anecho it kind of really depends
yeah but there's a new style that's very
interesting that's called the cristalino
that is being brought to the market
which is actually a nieco
that's clear so what they do is they
there's a filtration system with
with carbon that takes out all the color
of the of the anecho and and renders it
renders it clear
so you have the same flavor profile of
ajejo but it's completely clear
just is aesthetic so it's it's
aesthetics and it also doesn't like
intimidate people you know it's
when they think it's gonna be like oh
nieko it's like drinking a cognac or
an old scotch you like it's gonna be
some big thing in your mouth
so it's kind of like a little bit of a
perception thing as well
so tell me about wine i wanna know why
you got into wine because you know what
here we are first of all i got to give
you some love
all your beautiful wines because i'm all
about promoting my friends
making sure they have everything that
they need so this is yours
this is your 2016 which is uh with your
distributors here in town so graciously
sent me and it's so
uh zombium i love that
so somni um yeah it means dream latin
that's our new label so we've we've just
launched so it started with the
cabernet and then we made the rose
um yep so we make that what's called
sanye style so we bleed off
um from the cabernet to make the rose
and then and then after that we came out
with sav blanc this year
and now we just launched the um we just
lost launch what i'm calling the red
label
which is the more accessible price point
that we actually we use a lot of estate
wine in it
but we buy a little bit of blending
grapes to sort of like round it off and
make it
um a little more ready to drink right
now
yeah so we add some merlot and really
just kind of make this wonderful
wonderful much much much more accessible
price point wine so
you know it's all about that portfolio
right yeah totally
no i just think it's like wine just
because like you love tequila like i
i mean you just kind of fall in love
with it but i think that you know
there's such a romantic
process to making a have you been wine
tasting much
yes absolutely my sister my older sister
is the estate manager of a vineyard in
napa called hudson
oh and hudson and by the way if you guys
want to buy some grapes down the road
i'm just going to have to plug my
sister's
you know vineyard and where she works at
called hudson
and for many years they have been
selling grapes to all the big houses in
napa and sonoma um
um the gentleman's was the owner's name
lee hudson awesome dude
this iconic kind of wine maker in napa
and
so yeah so i've i've loved wine i've
tasted a lot i've gone through and done
all the tours
i've been to spain i've been to france
to taste yeah i'm i'm
really into it for me i was so struck by
the
um just how much labor goes into each
vintage
and how every vintage is rare
you're never going to have another one
and so um
hence the reason why you never want to
waste a bottle because you're not going
to make it again
um totally um but but i just think that
for me it's the
the the farming of it and the love that
goes into it that's so amazing and
just how much time it takes i don't
think anyone understands just how many
steps and levels there are and how much
like hands-on care there is so that's
kind of you know and then you know of
course
anything that anything that joins people
together
in the in the spirit of connecting and
sharing
and you might not even be talking about
the wine um you might be talking about
the food
uh or you might just be talking about a
bunch of random crap because you're with
your friends
like anything that brings people
together in this day and age especially
and away from technology and connecting
people i think is such a great thing
which is
you know the point for me of making the
wine and keeping that going
slowing down and creating conversation
oh 100
you know i agree i mean and it's so
volatile grapes are
so they're on a timetable looking right
now my sister
is so busy because it's harvest right
now it's only the beginning of september
because of the heat
so every year totally changes and you
have to be on your toes and ready to
adapt and overcome
yeah i love that about wine i just think
it's so fun it's organic it's living i
think
and it's the perfect pairing to
fantastic food and that's why i love it
you know so what what goes best with
um mexican cuisine what do you think
like what
is there because obviously like i mean
like i've sat down to dinner before and
anything that's really spicy
it's tough to pair like especially a red
wine with so
help me out what would i what would i
pair with what would i pair with the
mexican oh yeah
a blend a blend like this is delicious
because
you think about the blending of chilies
right so it's very typical like if i
make a mole
which would have a mixture of maybe
three to five different chilies
so i'm i'm i'm thinking of the chilies
like grapes
so a blend like yours right here would
be ideal for it because it could stand
up to the heat
except what i'm saying you don't want
something that's very flabby
you don't want a gamma you don't want a
very light pinot
you don't want you don't you don't want
even a grenache necessarily because i
think
the food would dominate the wine so you
want something that stands up to it
like this and complements it perfectly
so
something like this beautiful cat blend
that you have that you do
that's here that i'm tasting would be
ideal for like a mole or enchiladas or
something with a red chili based sauce
yeah uh and then you mentioned you guys
are going to launch a soft blanc right
we did yeah oh you did okay yeah like
for a sod blanc for me
um you know like ceviche something with
citrus and chili and herbs
would always be ideal with salt blanc
oysters is probably the most
you know common thing that you would
think of you know
so you know and i think that's why your
wines pay so go so well with like
emerald's food
because emerald has a lot of a lot of
seafood in his in his
in his style in his in his menus so i
think
that would really work well as as well
so
i was actually talking to my friend this
weekend
and she was talking about how kids are
you know not dating as much even
like i mean those we're talking about
young kids but i'm wondering
just as like an example of um what's
going on
that they're not really dating as much
but they're super friendly like they're
facetiming all the time they're doing
social media like they
they they're they've got tons of friends
but like the more intimate connections
are maybe
fading like green how
what's how do you how do we remedy this
yeah yeah
well you know it's interesting because
you know i have a lot of you know
millennials and young people that work
with me at the restaurants and stuff and
and they're around me all the time and
it's interesting because in their mind
they think they're doing all these
things because they they're they're
perceiving it through social media or
youtube or
but they haven't done the work yet you
got to go do the work
you know what i mean and so i think it's
i think every i think this new
generation is very um idealistic
i think they all have great plans i
think they're extremely smart
and well prepared you better be well
prepared as a young person now
there's no excuses you have access to
information
everywhere it's the biggest thing is
putting into work
you know what i mean is going out there
and doing it and i think
that hopefully will happen and it
happens with relationships
with business you know with life
experiences
you just got to go out there and do it
you know and i think hopefully
you know i think this new generation is
because there's so much competition
like back in the day like when i started
if i got in timeout magazine or new york
magazine
i was already a baller before the
internet you know what i mean
but now people are self-made experts
and little brands and little iconic
people in society because of social
media
so you know what i'm saying so it's you
know
like the competition of being recognized
and
and separate from the pack is a lot
harder now because
everyone has the potential of being
somebody
because they're on these little damn
things all the time you know what i mean
isn't that the new work though figuring
out how to be like a
how to do it on the social platforms
figuring out how to connect in that way
and you know i feel like that's part of
the new world though
i'll give you an example okay so when i
started cooking
you know 25 years ago you would hire a
traditional publicist right a pr person
right and then they would get you a
placement in new york times they get
your placement in la times
and all that and that was like what you
wanted you know
um and that was huge get your review out
there
you know that was it and now that
style of traditional pr is gone now in
like my team we all invest in social
media now
i have two two kids that are that are on
my team that just
do that 100
so yes we have a traditional pr person
too
that does some other things for me but
it's that's where we're at now
and and now you know like for people
like you and i were
you know we have a narrative we have a
point of view that people want to see
you know it's not enough just to do
random posts we have to look at
our posts on instagram as a business
opportunity
and it's hard for people that are fans
of ours to be like oh man you know
i feel like you know you're just posting
you know your marketing partners are
doing this that and the other
so that's that balance that we have to
figure out is how to like
do personal stuff let people into our
world but also use it as a business
tool i agree i totally agree i think
that
social media is uh you have to stay you
have to
stick to the stick to the original
reason why people pay attention
to it which is that they get a little
insight into your life
and they see you in a different way than
what
normally you see on tv and so they get
to know you better so
like my argument with the socials was
has always been that
you know i i you know i really
because i mean it's sharing is something
that's not super hard for me
but it's also like how much do you
really want to share and
um but it's got to be and then there's
also people who
you know whether it be somnium or my new
label danica rose
or whether it be selling my book or
whether it be
you know promoting my podcast or
whatever it may be people get a little
worn out
they want you to promote it like all the
people that are involved
want to want you to promote it but i'm
like you gotta go like i don't know i
think them i think it's like
80 90 percent like
you and then the rest of it the small
percentage has got to be
the things yeah i get the motion yeah
yeah i
i get it you know and for you you're i
mean
you know just because you're i again i'm
going to come back to what my mom and
you have in common it's like you you
guys
went into a male-dominated field and you
guys
kicked ass and you had to be
staunch with the way you handle your
business starts with
how much you let people in so for
someone like you
is a lot different from me in the sense
because i've done tv for so long and i
think people kind of know me a little
bit
but you you've kind of you've been under
the helmet you know literally
and you know for some a big part of your
life and then now
you're out and people are very intrigued
on what you have to say
you know what i mean because you just
had to be like boom boom focus you know
what i'm saying
so i just think we you know we we owe a
service to people that
follow us and i think that's why you
can't be lazy with social media and
things like that
because we created a platform and we
have to deliver
why did you why did you write a memoir
you know what at 45 years old i didn't
think i thought it was too young to do
it to be honest i thought you did that
when you're older you know
but i've lived a lot of life very
quickly because of my mom
and how i just how everything rolled out
for me
and i wanted to make sure that
the new generation was prepared uh
and understand that you can have faults
you can have problems with addiction you
can have problems with depression
you can lose one of your parents you can
do all these things and it's okay
you don't have to be ashamed of it you
know i went on the dr oz's show
you know because daphne now is a new
judge on masterchef junior and she's
amazing and i wanted to show it i just i
let it all out i didn't care
you know what i'm i'm not ashamed and i
wanted
that this the memoir to be more so than
anything an inspirational tale
but also a cautionary one don't make the
mistakes i made
and granted it was a different time but
i wanted to be this
this sort of something tangible that
that people can sort of
uh get inspiration from you know and and
and see if they see
some similarities in the way they're
brought up or who they are
so that was why i wanted to do it you
know and it was very cathartic it was
super
therapeutic to like purge you know what
i'm saying and just
sit there and let it all out it was like
a big old therapy session it was awesome
what was the hardest thing to share
i think you know aspects of my the
family dynamics
i think you know everybody you know you
want to
you know you want your dad to be your
hero and you want to be
spotless and not have any um
any your shortcomings and any any
dark sides of them and that just wasn't
me so that was a big
you know that wasn't my that my dad had
a lot of
things he had to deal with you know so
that was
uh that was very difficult for me to
share because everyone
you know i have a nine-year-old son i
want my son to look at me as
the superman you know and uh
i kind of understood some of some of the
things he did that was hard to mention
and so that was hard and then i guess
the other part of just like the
depression you know and
you know being having way too much too
much responsibility too young
i took on too much too young and i just
had to kind of deal with it
so then i kind of retreated you know
personally and
you know i needed more mentoring i
needed more life experiences but i just
took it on and
dealt with it and then i think i
suffered a little bit just from a
happiness standpoint
because i was so involved in my craft i
was just that's all i did
and i didn't know how to have any
balance so what's the
what was your recommendation then to
slow that down to get to how would you
how would you redo it
and re you know repackage that for the
for someone that was listening that
you know is on this super fast path
maybe and
you know you just it's a slippery slope
and what happens with athletes all the
time you know
you know you become a prodigy right and
you got people telling you what to do
all the time and you know how to live
your life what to eat you know
and all that kind of stuff and i mean
for me i just think you gotta
you gotta schedule personal time for
yourself like you schedule business
right
so that's what i've done like i schedule
my family time my schedule time for me
like when i want to work out or i want
to go away and
you know on a retreat with no one around
so you
that would be one recommendation and
another recommendation is just
you know figure out you know just have
all your goals written down
you know for me i didn't have like i
didn't have goals like i knew i wanted
to own my own restaurant that was my
dream
but at the end of the day you just gotta
you know put everything down like i have
my board back here where i write things
down and
that's helpful because when i get up and
have coffee in the morning i know what
we need to attack
what's on it well i mean right
what are you willing to share i have no
i have all these proteins and stuff like
this
all these different flavor combinations
that i have here especially let's see if
you can see
i just don't want to break it oh okay
ground beef pasta black beans fennel
so you know all the different sauces so
it just reminds me of all the different
flavor combinations
so like that's something i did the other
day and you know just
trying to always uh have a goal and be
productive
like well you know what i taught my son
i said we're gonna we
how we're gonna attack every day is
we're gonna wake up we're gonna do
something physical
right so we go to the gym or we work out
we go to the park we have to do
something physical
feed our body then we're going to feed
our minds so we're going to read or
we're going to go to a museum or we're
going to
try to feed our mind and get right then
we'll feed our bodies
by eating something and then you can
have free time
and do what you want wow where did you
learn like where did that i just came up
with
i just came up with it but was it is
this a quarantine rule or is it yeah
well it's a quarantine rule kind of but
yeah i was just like
because i'm just a person that has to be
working all the time
so i've had to become creative to how to
kind of take this energy and
take it put it somewhere you know
[Music]
so this is with your son right yeah my
[ __ ] what does
uh and you said he's nine so this is
such good lessons
for someone that's nine years old to
just understand
that you know oh wow i should do
something for my mind
okay wow how does he was he was he
receptive to it or yeah well i mean
he goes with the flow i mean but you
know
he much likes the the nerf gun war will
have
you know or he likes you know he likes
the other stuff but you know but we have
to sit him down
he has to read for 45 minutes you know
and
so you know he knows what time it is
we'll have a
you know not in this home but my la
house um
you know i have like a whole little
library area and i just
leave the book there and he goes i know
hello
i gotta read i'm like yeah bro sorry
so that was the good things you know
yeah that's amazing what what um
what are your some what are some of your
things what do you do
yourself other than making sure you plan
some you know
down time and and yeah well what else do
you do
i like to be out in the open in the
woods you know what i mean
i like to be in nature you know so
whether it's fishing or
hiking and doing all that cool stuff i
like i love that
i love being outside um yeah and then
you know i do the typical
workout stuff and all that i played
basketball when i was young
so i'll go out there and shoot some
hoops you know i did this
the nba celebrity all-star game
a couple years back here in new orleans
and it was hilarious
you know like playing basketball in the
superdome
you know what i mean in front of all
these people and you know
it was a trip so yeah so basketball big
sports guy obviously
i love racing i love that and
you know just kicking back i love
museums i go to museums all the time
love art oh really yeah
me too yeah i'm recently single so
like for me to go to yeah awesome
okay i love it i love it
um but you know for me it's you know
i can't think of a better day you know
than take somebody to a
to a museum you know and have a little
late lunch
what kind of art do you like i like all
of it you know
um i'm like super nerdy when it comes to
um like i'm fascinated with vikings
i watch all those viking shows god i
love that i kind of feel like i used to
be a viking because did you know that
women women fought with the men yes
being fought with the men that's why i
love it
i like i really feel like at some point
in time i was at the front of one of
those viking ships coming across the
ocean
like you know you know what you'd be
called a shield maiden
is is the ladies that fought right
alongside their men
how badass is that and women back in
nordic times can
divorce dudes which was like in in
the 9th century that was like unheard of
you could divorce a dude
you know you can have a lover on the
side like it was cool man like
so my mom's 100 norwegian so there you
go so
there's a real chance that maybe there's
some viking blood in me
i love it well there's a reason that
you're such a badass
and then the other thing that i feel is
like the more like
mayan aztec culture like there's some
there's a chance that i also was uh you
know
running the show as a mayan queen or
something like that
i mean why do we make ourselves out to
be these superheroes i don't know
nobody ever said nobody ever said man
you know i saw myself as
i saw myself as a plumber and nothing
wrong with them right or you know nobody
said like i
saw myself working at a fast food joint
you know like
nobody ever saw them so they only see
themselves as like viking queens and
you know like somebody that ran the
world right yeah
and that's so hard you know i always
tell people because i have a lot of
friends that are from mexico and from
abroad and they always tell me like
we'll have wine and we'll like
we'll have like deep talks and they say
you know you americans you define
yourselves by your jobs
you know we live to work
they work to live you know what i'm
saying in other countries
we're so defined with our work and
i'm this and that people just want to be
happy
work is just a means to your happiness
you know what i'm saying
so that's why they take holiday for a
month and a half
in europe and all those kind of things
because it's important
to have family time and or in alone time
or whatever
so i think that's important but for me
people like you and i
we're screwed because we just i think we
want to just always
approve upon and find that next goal and
get it done
because we've built something and you
want to continue to build it you know
it's not going to be happy with how many
layers you have
it has to get bigger you know there is
some because there is some joy in that
right i don't think determined an
accomplishing thing
means that you're disconnected from
yourself in a way that
um you know you're not happy at all
there is some joy in accomplishing there
is some joy in
doing something that you love but i
think that's the trick
right that's the trick is finding
something that you
love to do instead of you know um
just something that makes you a bunch of
money is actually really loving to do it
so
you know i think you i mean to me like
there's no question that you found it
would you do you question
whether or not you found that i i i
can't even imagine myself doing anything
else
and i know it's a cliche but i don't
feel like i really work
i just love what i do you know what i
mean and that's allowed me to pay more
attention
to other things that are important like
relationships like
family you know giving back you know
that's why i have my scholarship
where i put latino kids into culinary
school uh
you know and currently i have like nine
kids enrolled they go to culinary school
in new york city and it's been one of
the most grateful
uh things that i've done in the last
last few years is
planting seeds for that next generation
you know the lifestyle that i've
afforded now and
the things i have is because i'm cooking
you know what i mean
which is a humble job you have to
remember
in just 20 years ago chefs were
forgotten people we were in the back now
chefs are
brands now chefs or this that and the
other
you know and you can thank emeril our
buddy you can thank
gordon for that ramsay you can you know
for
they've literally changed the pace thank
you
thank thank you yes we've we've
literally changed the pay scale for
chefs
we've given more we've given we've
changed the marketplace
you know what i mean as far as how we
should be compensated how we should be
recognized and treated
all those things are now different now
yeah and this is the other thing danica
was like in my book
i was there at the inception of the
celebrity chef i know
that that [ __ ] before i was there when
it was happening
where we were getting paid this what
year well i mean it's like right when
food network with food network early 90s
like 25 years
yeah mid 90s mid 90s 25 30 years is how
about how old
is that about how old that well maybe 20
years since it's been
really popping where chefs begin like
they're just due
you know what i mean and so it's it's
it's crazy to see what's happened you
know like i know
i'm no longer just a guy that cooks you
know i'm like
like a cultural person that changes
opinions and
and people look up to me and i mentor
people and that there's so much going on
now you know
as opposed it's just simple cooking
when you say that and say like mentoring
and inspiring
um what was your
relationship with that at first
you know i mean because i lost my daddy
when i was young
and i needed to have um
older people to help guide me you know
so i
really needed mentoring when i was very
young like 16 17 i was in a very
volatile time
and i you know i was resisting at first
but then
now and now i'm so thankful of it
um and the biggest part about mentoring
is making time you know like my kids
we try to set up a weekly call i call my
kids but
there's my scholarship resist the
scholarship recipients
you know that are in my program i try to
make sure that i speak to them once a
week and just
you know what are you guys doing like
talk to me about your cooking
do you miss your family you know
whatever and that's mentoring that's
giving them a little hug
and being like hey i got your back i'm
thinking about you you know what i mean
so it's so important in the restaurant
business is mentoring and just
you know finding somebody that can take
you one stop
and then you find another mentor and
then they they can do that
because you know being a part of being a
successful chef
is developing your own style danica
it's not about regurgitating the lessons
from your mentor because then you just
become a clone
so the real key in being and this
happens in any facet of art in my
opinion
you take all of those lessons that
you've learned from the people that have
influenced you
and then through that process you
develop your own voice
you know what i'm saying your own
identity through those mentors that
you've had
and that way you separate yourself from
them but still pay homage to them you
know what i mean
how did you do that well it was through
travel
and through being a rebel i'm not i'm a
tough son of a [ __ ]
like i don't like people telling me what
to do since i was young i was like
my mom used to say i'm like a there's a
great word that you should learn it's
called uh amanzado
and it means to season uh so like my mom
grew up in a cattle ranch so you would
have a bronco or a horse
that no one could ride that that horse
because it was such a pain in the ass
but it was strong
you would have to unmanned side the
horse you'd have to break it in
hmm so i'm i needed to be broken in
instead of saying because i was like i
had all the talent
yeah i was wild and and i had all
you know i had all the strength and all
the ability but i just didn't know how
to listen
you know so once you get broken in and
you get right
you know what i mean it's something
really beautiful
so i just needed to start to listen do
you remember
do you remember when that happened like
was there a story of like you were like
oh yeah i get it now
yeah um well the biggest one
as i worked at kate paul chef paul
perdon arguably one of the most
recognizable chefs in the country
we used to do book signings uh like at a
fancy food show or whatever there'd be
500 people
waiting to see him you know 400 pounds
in a buggy
women throwing themselves at him
throwing themselves at them
like here's my number chef call me later
i'm like holy [ __ ] like you know
crazy stuff you know so i worked there
and i did a job
where i had to like work six in the
morning to six pm and i had to make
big things of chicken stock like 50
gallons of chicken stock and do all this
and you would have to
taste anything you made you had to get
into the chefs and they would approve it
they would say oh
that's good or needs this and that so i
met this girl the day before on my day
off
on canal street here in new orleans and
this is pre-cell phone
so i'm like hey baby i get done at six
tomorrow
meet me here at 6 30 and we'll go on a
date right
so i'm like hauling ass at work that day
because i needed to go meet her
and at four o'clock i brought this
jalapeno vinegar
it's three ingredients vinegar sugar and
jalapenos i messed it up of course
because i was rushing the chef taste it
he tastes and goes oh man that's not
right boy
do it again i'm like sure to clean up
bringing back the same [ __ ] the same
vinegar
in front of all my colleagues and i'm 16
by the way
so i'm like i'm like a knucklehead you
know
or i might have been 18 because i came
back when i was 18. regardless i was
still a knucklehead
so i bring it back and he sees it and he
goes
you must think i'm an idiot huh it was
so so embarrassing everyone was walking
away from me they're like you messed up
i don't
and then without missing a beat he goes
what's your name
he goes what's your name i go oh chef
her name's christina
uh she's really hot and he's like
well say goodbye to christina cause you
working tonight
so i never had a chance to go you know
what i mean
so it was a great lesson and that was
like the last shortcut i ever took
you know because it's gonna come out at
the end you know what i mean there's no
use fighting
are there any other things that you feel
like you've had to learn the hard way
that have really changed your life like
the most influential things in your life
to get you to where you are now
um well you know
i think being honest with my my marriage
that didn't work out i think was a big
part of like
who i am now just you know
when you when you that's like when you
pray you prioritize
work and then you know you're not you're
not present and you're not there
and you know that was something that i
took for granted
so now i'm very much more present now
you know
i'm aquarius so i'm very aloof oh i
looked that up i saw your birthdays in
february i was like oh
no wonder why you have all the tattoos
no wonder why you're a chef
because you're super creative you're
eclectic
you're awful you're just you're just
like aquarius people are just
you know they march to the beat of their
own drum exactly
and one of the biggest things about
being an aquarius is that you're aloof
so you always like in my mind i always
think and people i know what people are
thinking of me
but i become better shh
sorry um
i'm just glad my dogs haven't barked yet
one of them sleeping on the other side
of this
desk and then the other one is sleeping
somewhere where it's cold so
do you guys have older dogs or younger
they're five and six
so do you live with your family no i
live by myself
oh wow remember we talked about this
newly single yeah
okay i've been single in 16 years
and where do you live in uh california
no i'm in scottsdale
in scottsdale do you know do you know um
scott you know scott yeah gotta sit down
i i saw i ran into him at the grocery
store a while back
they call him scotty the hottie by the
way
[Laughter]
okay but he's very much marriage that
marriage marriage
he's pretty much married i love it
but uh yeah that's funny anyway
[Music]
life's understanding as little lessons
you know i mean i think that you know
you talk about
like you know marriage and prioritizing
work but that's that that's so many
people's story that's not just
i think that yes do i think it's
probably harder for someone who's
you know in a partnership with someone
who is in the world of
you know in the restaurant business and
working weird hours and long hours and
the harder you work the more you make
kind of thing i mean but that's
there's a lot of business i mean that's
that's a lot of people's story
yeah i agree i agree and it's good to
say it you know it's there's something
really
special about just being like this is
where i'm at in life the coolest part
about getting older is knowing what you
want
you know what i mean and being like all
right i you know
i'm looking for this or this is what you
know makes me happy and
but still being open at the same time so
you kind of have to be like
play that game you know what are those
things that you've
come to realize more recently that uh
make you happy um
i think meeting new people i think um
having people like having exchanges with
someone that were something
uh where they're vulnerable and you have
the the honor of getting to know that
the privilege of getting to know
someone's
heart i think that's something so
special
you know my mom told me a great piece of
why she goes never
mess with a woman's heart you'll be in
trouble boy
you know just be honest if you treat
people with honesty and respect you'll
never go back
just tell them you know this is who i am
or this is what i'm about
like if you don't if it's not for you
then whatever
you know move on but just be honest and
be respectful
you know has that been easy and natural
for you all along or is that more
something
that do you think that takes age to do
that
or is that just to just take the parent
the right parent to tell you to do that
yeah it takes an age and experience you
know
like yeah i've been married once um
yeah i've been in some relationships but
i've had a lot of great lovers too
in between you know wait hang on what's
the difference between
uh relationships and lovers is that is
that not what i love
is what the kids call hooking up now but
people in the states
and and you're in europe uh you call it
a lover
you know what i mean but i don't think
there's nothing wrong with saying that
you know what i mean
yeah but they but they would they would
view the ladies would view me the same
way
you know but talk about throughout my
life
like i've been with like five women that
are just
absolute keepers in my time that were
that should have been
you know and they're they're married now
and they're doing their thing but at the
time i didn't realize it you know what
i'm saying
were they just lovers yeah we just had
you know we were kicking it having a
good time but
i just didn't you know what i mean and
it was just like so
you know so that but that's that's a
relationship person i'm like
wow i've never even crossed my mind like
to be a lover
to like love someone that's not it's not
serious
yeah well i mean everyone's different no
no it might be
great yeah it's it's i mean for me it's
just because
the i mean i travel 200 days a year you
know what i'm saying
you know back before all this went down
like so it's not like i'm anywhere at
one time
for a long time so you know you find
yourself in these places you know what i
mean
so you're an aquarius an aquarius as
well
so but yeah but now you know as i'm
getting older you know
i don't know you know it's just what
else makes you happy
what do you do for fun what do you do
for fun
well you know we i like to ride horses
i'm into that
i think that's really cool because my
family grew up in a cattle ranch i dig
that
um what else
like you know i like to tour vineyards
you know i think i love doing that
museums i said that earlier
you know i work all the time so it's
like for me like when somebody asks me
what my hobby is or what i like to do
for fun it's
[ __ ] you know i don't really think about
it you know what i mean
i just find myself in like with friends
mostly swimming
going to the ocean i love being in the
water
you know fun stuff like that yeah what
about you
um you know the older i get
the more um and especially being done
with racing
and you know kind of really realizing
that something that i loved about it was
putting myself in uncomfortable
situations and overcoming it and facing
it
so now as i'm away from racing i find
myself doing things like jumping off of
a cliff
or learning how to learning how to wake
surf or
something like that or you know back
when i when i hosted the espys like
saying yes to things that are kind of
scary or different
um more so so yeah kind of pushing
myself
challenging myself but you're an
adrenaline junkie
i'm not that's not it no it's not about
the adrenaline in fact adrenaline scares
the [ __ ] out of me
it's um more about new things
it's about knowing that if i have to
push the
if i have to push my comfort zone to a
place that it's not been before
or a place that's just not comfortable
that i know i can do it
yeah i understand what you say like i'm
afraid of heights
i hate heights so i went bungee jumping
i am no less afraid of heights i'm still
afraid of heights but i like to know
that if i need to jump i can still jump
yeah i hear you man we went we shot
the show i had in in mexico we i went on
an
air balloon with uh
yeah yeah hot air balloon with the chef
uh my co-host and we fulfilled someone's
dream because they have never won they
never
can afford to go on to a hot air balloon
i was scared shitless
but there was one point where you break
the cloud line
and you see all the other hot air
balloons going around you and it was
something
so special you know and that helped me
calm a little bit of that
fear you know what i mean so yeah
there's things like that that need to
happen
in time it's easy just to be insulated
you know
yeah is that so is that something that i
mean is that
i feel like a lot of people are more
brave than i am i don't know people
think that i'm brave because i drove a
race car but
you know i think there's a lot of people
that just are much more brave and like
they just do
they they say yes and do random stuff
all the time
but maybe not yeah comfort
do you find that you stay in your
comfort zone most of the time or do you
like
do you get out of do you do you push
yourself
you have to you have to man like i'm a
big homebody before covert [ __ ]
like i like watching all the shows and
my my little forensic files and all that
and then you know there'd be times
it'd be a friday night you know by
myself i should be out
you know what i'm saying just
interacting with people you know
or but i just want to kick back on the
couch or whatever so like things like
that
and you know not not finding excuses to
go visit a friend
you know in another city and be like hey
man let me just catch up
you know i miss you you know so those
are things that i've gotten better about
you know being more spontaneous and
random and just jumping on a plane and
getting somewhere and
you know hey man what's up i missed you
you know
let's go eat let's go have a good time
what are you most looking forward to
doing when
all of these sort of restrictions and
quarantine stuff
music festivals i love music festivals
because i cook at a lot of them bottle
rock um yeah
all all the big all the big ones that uh
austin yeah the city limits all the
voodoo fest here in new orleans so
i miss music i miss live music i miss
being out
just going from one little field to the
other and having another
you know stage there where someone's
playing music and then running over here
that's the thing i miss the most and
going to live sporting events
you know that's the other one i miss a
lot yeah
yeah of course and of course restaurants
that are packed
you know what i mean you got even sick
of cooking at
all like i love cooking too i think i
mean like i was
saying before to my producer i feel like
i know a lot of chefs because i've done
a lot of
you know cooking shows and things like
that and i just truly love cooking
um but even i get you know i mean i get
sick of cooking
no i don't ever get sick of cooking it's
like it's like uh
you know they don't look you know a lot
of have a lot of friends that are
musicians and they always ask me are you
sick of playing that song
and they go if i get sick of playing
that song then i'm gonna start
playing songs you know so like it's just
something you always love
you know i never get tired of it i i
love it so
um well that's when you know that you're
really doing
what you love i gotta i gotta go baby i
have something to do
i'm sorry no it's good no i can sit here
and talk to you all
night no i think that's a perfect way i
think that's a perfect way to end you're
living
you're you probably got to go cook yeah
sadly but i just wanted to say thank you
so much
yeah you're absolutely special you're
like a big
beam of light i really have to say that
you're a wonderful
these lights shining on maybe no no
you're the op
you're the example of the epitome of a
strong woman that is
continuing to redefine themselves and
make people happy
you should feel really great about
yourself and what you do every day okay
thank you a wonderful soul
and i hope i see you again soon if i
have to come to new orleans and bring my
wine and you bring your tequila
we got it all day long all right thank
you
bye sweetie thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more
please click on the subscribe button